we're told that kai goes to a restaurant
that advertises a promotion saying
one in five customers get a free dessert
suppose kai goes to the restaurant twice
in a given week and each time he has a
one-fifth probability of getting a free
dessert
let x represent the number of free
desserts chi
gets in his two trips construct the
theoretical probability distribution of
x alright so pause this video and see if
you can work through this before we do
it together
all right so first let's just think
about the possible values that x could
take on this is the number of free
desserts he gets and he visits twice
so there's some world in which he
doesn't get any free desserts
so that's zero in his two visits
maybe on one of the visits he gets a
dessert and the other one he doesn't
and maybe in both of his visits he
actually is able to get a free dessert
so he's going to have some place from 0
to 2 free desserts in a given week
so we just have to figure out the
probability of each of these
so let's first of all think about the
probability
let me write it over here the
probability that
capital x is equal to zero is going to
be equal to what
well that's going to be the probability
that he doesn't get a dessert on
both days and it's important to realize
that these are independent events it's
not like the restaurant's gonna say oh
if you didn't get a dessert on one day
you're more likely to get another day or
somehow if you got it on a previous day
you're less likely on another day
that they are independent events so the
probability of not getting it on any one
day
is four out of five
the probability of not getting it on two
of the days i would just multiply them
because they are independent events
so 4 over 5 times 4 over 5.
so the probability that x is equal to 0
is going to be 16
twenty-fifths sixteen over twenty-five
now what about the probability that x
is equal to one what is this going to be
well there are two scenarios over here
there's one scenario where let's say on
day one
he does not get the dessert and on day
two he does
get the dessert but then of course
there's the other scenario
where on day one he gets the dessert and
then
on day two he doesn't
get the dessert these are the two
scenarios where he's going to get
x equals one and so if we add these
together let's see
four-fifths times one-fifth this is
going to be four
over twenty-five and then this is going
to be four
over twenty-five again and you add these
two together
you're going to get eight twenty-fifths
and then last but not least and actually
we could figure out this last one by
subtracting
16 and 8 from 25 which would actually
give us 1
25th but let's just write this out the
probability
that x equals 2 this is the probability
gets a desert on both days
so one fifth chance on day one
and one fifth chance on the second day
so one-fifth times one-fifth
is 1 25th and you can do a reality check
here these all need to add up to one and
they do indeed add up to 1.
16 plus 8 plus 1 is 25 so 25
25 is what they all add up to and we're
done